[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy labor day
speaking of
jobs the judge
[Music]
who is going to appoint a special master
obviously does not know her [ __ ] job
very well
doesn't understand the assignment at all
but is this really a surprise i mean no
one should be really surprised that this
judge breaking news by the way
the the judge in the
document stealing case where the former
guy stole our top secret documents
and harbored them and then obstructed
justice and still is obstructing justice
because there's empty folders so those
documents are [ __ ] somewhere they're
somewhere i don't know if he ate them i
don't flush him down a toilet i don't
know if he put him in a casket somewhere
or he sold them i have no idea but we we
need to get to the bottom of this
why he had our documents and what the
[ __ ] happened to him
why did you steal them why did you
harbor them why did you keep them unsafe
and why did you get where the [ __ ] are
they in those [ __ ] empty folders
where are they
where are the [ __ ] documents you
piece of [ __ ]
but the judge
the judge down in florida the trump
appointed judge
i don't know what she was given for this
maybe she was given a
an an hors d'oeuvre of classified
documents as possible you know maybe she
likes ketchup too
she is appointed a special master which
is irrelevant really and don't freak out
about this
because here's the thing is the fbi
taint team has already done this job
so if this special master is appointed
this special master cannot go outside
the bounds of the law and any special
master here is gonna understand the law
better than this judge
i understand it better than this judge
and i'm not even a [ __ ] attorney
and really i think this opens trump up
to to more criminal liability here
to have someone else say
yeah you shouldn't add these [ __ ]
documents like there's a few things in
here that are a turning client privilege
but the fbi has already sorted that out
i mean how how is it going to look when
a special master that's appointed by a
trump judge because trump wanted the
special master goes yeah they're doing
their job
they did their job
they did their job they made sure that
anything that was privileged inside
those boxes
was separated and isn't used as quote
unquote evidence because he's under
criminal
investigation that's the other thing
that is absolutely bonkers batshit crazy
that this country does not understand
this guy is under criminal investigation
not just in florida for stealing top
secret for espionage
he is he is under criminal investigation
at january 6 for obstructing an official
proceeding
treason
he's under investigation in new york for
financial crimes him and his [ __ ]
trump org oh well he's not indicted yet
yet
yet that's the deal with alan
weisselberg the judge made the deal with
alan weisenberg says you're gonna sing
[ __ ]
you're going to sing
and in georgia
this guy's under criminal investigation
look
this is [ __ ] ridiculous that these
nazis get to have some kind of rally and
wherever the [ __ ] they were i guess it
was pennsylvania they had the other the
other hitler on stage masteriano is that
his [ __ ] name
this guy this [ __ ] white supremacist
is queuing on white supremacists he's an
insurrectionist too by the way
who's gonna get his [ __ ] ass kicked
by shapiro
the same way dr oz is gonna get dunked
in the trash by fetterman
because the american people are sick of
this [ __ ] garbage they're sick of it
they're sick of you [ __ ] manga
fascist criminals coming out and telling
us what the [ __ ] we're gonna do
enough of this [ __ ]
especially on a day like today labor day
the fascist has never
never been for labor
they've always been for the corporations
they always will be
and the american people are waking up to
this nonsense that somehow they're
populist they are not populist
they are not
they're fear mongers
they want to control you they want to
control your labor they want to control
your body they want to control your
marriage they want to control your
parenting they want to control your
education they want to control
everything that's what fascists do
they want to control your religion
all of it think about it think about
it that's what they want to do they want
to tell you what the [ __ ] to do and it
doesn't play well with americans
that's not populism folks that's not
even close they're disguising it as that
because they're like oh i'm rubber
you're glue
whatever you say that i'm a fascist
bounces off me and sticks to you joe
biden really dumb it's really stupid
it's really [ __ ] stupid and
speaking
then
the i'm rubber your glue
defense this morning marco rubio says
that the case at mar-a-lago is about
storage no dummy it's not about storage
you're a dumb [ __ ] you are a
dumb [ __ ] here's what they're
trying to do
they're trying to say this is about
storage of documents
because that's really honestly when you
boil down the email lady case why they
were so [ __ ] upset that was a storage
issue
that literally was a storage issue and
she fixed the storage issue she handed
over where she had those emails the all
the the emails about the [ __ ] wedding
cake and the wedding planning she handed
that over in the server
and there was one one email three that
were questionable one that had a
confidential marking that was wrong
this [ __ ] stole
our top secret documents
that have human assets on it the more i
think about this the more i believe the
reason why donald trump because he
doesn't know what these documents are
come on you really think this
[ __ ] didn't take briefings
unless it had his name on it
unless they told the story and it had a
coloring book page with a sharpie
and had to have his name all over it had
to be about him
these secret top secret documents these
confidential documents aren't some rando
documents they're not
they're two things they're either a
about him 100 percent full stop they're
about him their investigations
confidential information that was given
classified information that was given
from sources overseas about him and his
[ __ ] family and his [ __ ]
organization
and it's also documents that someone
wants
that he can sell he never does anything
that doesn't benefit him jesus christ
you look at his [ __ ] nazi rally this
weekend
his pity party what a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] getting on stage and whining that
you committed crime and you're being
held accountable the [ __ ] out of here
man oh they broke into my house they
didn't break into your house dummy there
was a warrant it was a search warrant
you [ __ ] idiot
go go have that out in court
about about your [ __ ] rights
not not on stage
whining and crying that you're being
held held accountable for crime that you
committed
when the entire country knows you
committed this crime because it's not
hard it's not a far stretch
i don't even need to know that the
information that this [ __ ] stole
only benefited him
you don't even need to [ __ ] guess
that
why else would he take this [ __ ]
momento's top secret information for
momentos get the [ __ ] out of here and
then this this this piece of [ __ ]
floats the idea that it was for his
library well even in a library situation
which you are not gonna get a library
[ __ ] if we have anything to do
about it that should be one thing that
we as a people do not put up with our
democracies should not afford this
treasonous piece of [ __ ] a [ __ ]
building with his goddamn name on it
[ __ ] him
all his records can live in washington
at nara
put them down in the [ __ ] basement
and bury them somewhere [ __ ] them
but they don't put these type of
documents
in a presidential library
until they're actually declassified
meaning they go through the actual
process so nara can move them
from custody of of the archive in
washington
and then the safety of washington
where they're supposed to be stored
marco rubio
he stole them
and then
changed custody to a library that's the
[ __ ] documents that obama that he's
bitching about obama
they have to [ __ ] be sure that
they're stored and and in the proper
manner in the proper
place because if you just take them
that's stealing
that stealing because they're our
documents
they're ours
it's our [ __ ] [ __ ] not yours even if
even if
documents end up in a library somewhere
with the president's name on it like the
obama library or the bush library or the
clinton library that is still not theirs
they don't own it
we do
it's our building
it's ours
not theirs
this is really fun
we got to get this through his thick
[ __ ] skull and get it through the
rest of the country skull because that's
the one thing that is the disconnect
here [ __ ] the special master [ __ ] that
judge
really honestly [ __ ] if he's gonna get
indicted before the midterms this guy's
getting indicted on this thing there's
no question he's going to pay the price
for what he's done here because it's
much bigger than even what we know at
this point and the main thing is those
missing [ __ ] folders are the missing
documents out of the [ __ ] folders i
believe that
that's the case that they that's the
reason why they went there
in such a [ __ ] hurry
because they realized this son of a
[ __ ] was giving these things away
selling these [ __ ] or
destroying them
some of those things could it could be
all those things
because again there's no [ __ ] way you
can't convince me you can't convince me
that he took documents that had didn't
benefit him
no way no way did he pack up [ __ ] that
didn't benefit him personally at least
that was his view of it
that was his view
of how he decided
which top secret documents he was going
to steal from us
so here we are
again and i don't think it matters about
the special master i frankly think that
this special master [ __ ] only
only makes the case worse for him
it only shows the corruption that this
guy has
continued to be evolved in with the
court
with this [ __ ] trump appointed judge
cannon
it is only going to reveal
when they do get a special master
appointed
that yeah
the fbi did what they were supposed to
do over the last three weeks
they actually
separated out all the privileged stuff
we're not gonna
you know have the privileged stuff in
the evidence they did the correct thing
the fbi did their job the rest of this
stuff is evidence
i think is what's gonna happen
unless this judge just takes over and
appoints you know rudy giuliani is a
special master
now
don't knock on wood don't give them too
many ideas right
oh my god but they're going to act like
this is a [ __ ] victory right they're
going to go out there and act like it's
a victory he's probably posting about it
on fraud social right now
about how it's a big victory that they
got a special master ha ha ha nan
which only shows that he doesn't know
what a special master is in the first
place he didn't know what it was had no
clue if they really [ __ ] knew if him
and his attorneys knew what a special
master was they would have requested
while the fbi was still at his [ __ ]
home
gathering up all the boxes of [ __ ]
information that he stole from our
government
because that's the standard procedure
here when a box has [ __ ] in it that is
stolen from our government it doesn't
matter what else is in the box they take
the [ __ ] box they don't sort the box
there on the scene they take the [ __ ]
box
once they know it has [ __ ] that was
stolen in it
they take the box because it's all
evidence because it's all touching the
[ __ ] he stole
it really is not complicated to
understand
but him and the mogalo
and his nazi rally this weekend had no
[ __ ] clue
no [ __ ] clue
and we have some great footage from this
rally holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] do we have some great videos
from this rally this weekend this
[ __ ] nazi rally this manga fascist
rally
because that's what they are and keep
coming at them you know it really is
it really is telling when you call a
right-wing
white supremacist white christian
nationalist when you call him a fascist
you know
it hurts my feelings
i'm upset i'm offended
it only is telling
that you are a fascist why would you be
upset to be called a fascist if you're
not one like if someone called me a
fascist which i've had that happen
before people have called me a fascist
and i don't get upset or offended
i'm not offended i'm not upset
because i'm not one i
you call me nazi fascist all day long
and it really is going to affect me
i don't give a [ __ ]
because i'm i'm not one i'm not a nazi
i'm not a fascist but you are i'm a
liberal i believe in liberal democracy
i'm pro-democracy i believe people
should have their voice heard
speaking of that being labor day we see
now this year in this moment in time
this labor day we've had we have now
more
people who support labor unions in this
country than than years past
because they want democracy they want it
this country wants democracy they want
their [ __ ] voices heard
and the more these [ __ ] maga fascists
like these boneheads that showed up at
this [ __ ] nazi rally this weekend
and hailed margery taylor green what the
[ __ ] was she there for she does she's
not from the state of pennsylvania why
the [ __ ] is she there
is he is he trying to find a running
mate hmm
i wonder i wonder if he's trying to find
a running mate
good luck they're pro they're both
criminals they're probably both end up
in federal prison before you know it
before 2024.
i don't know i'm just saying
it's probably not a good idea to select
someone who's accused of being a pipe
bomber
to uh to be your vice presidential
running mate especially when you're you
know indicted on federal charges in
three different states probably not a
good idea i'm just saying i'm just
saying especially if she's indicted on
federal charges this is really [ __ ]
stupid
and then they go they have an
insurrectionist dan dan mastriano is
that his name master on am i saying that
right
mussolini is that how you say that he
kind of even looks like mussolini
doesn't he
and [ __ ] fascist uh
so he was on stage too because it's
pennsylvania
so of course of course the pennsylvanian
nazi shows up at the nazi rally but i
don't know i don't know if dr oz made it
over from new jersey or not i don't know
if he
he caught a car or caught a train over
from new jersey
and uh made it to the rally i'm not
really sure i didn't see any footage of
dr oz he must have been busy he must
have been busy in the state that he
actually lives in i don't know
i don't know i don't know i'm just
saying i'm just saying so we're gonna
watch we're gonna watch a lot of video
uh from the rally uh also i i gotta show
you this video of the good liars
brilliant brilliant video
absolutely brilliant video from the good
liars from the from the rally uh this
weekend
i've watched it several times and i
can't stop laughing every time i i watch
it because these people that they're
talking to just are [ __ ] just
clueless
clueless
of their boneheadedery and they're going
to continue this this nonsense you're
going to see this because we see it with
that cnn they have a new head at cnn cnn
is pushing this maga [ __ ] opec this
morning is scared
of dropping oil prices so they're gonna
they're gonna stave off production
corporations are are really scared folks
corporations are scared the fascists are
scared and the reason why they're scared
is because this country is [ __ ]
decided we want democracy
they watched kansas say no
to taking away women's bodily autonomy
and taking away people's rights kansas
said [ __ ] no
in new york's 19th in another
place that has been read before
they said absolutely not
we are not electing a [ __ ] fascist
republican no hell in way
in alaska
in alaska a democrat wins the first time
in almost 50 years
because republicans are fascist even
sarah palin
the [ __ ]
the mama bear the the lipstick lady i
don't know we were talking about this
the other day the lipstick line
i guess it's
hockey mom whatever
i i don't know anyway
anyways sarah palin couldn't even win
that race
she couldn't even [ __ ] win that race
i'm telling you they're terrified
they're [ __ ] terrified
the world's like oh [ __ ]
what's gonna happen if everyone in
democracies stand up and actually vote
pro-democracy and they vote for people
who are pro-democracy to set policies to
set pro-democracy policies we're [ __ ]
god we're gonna we're gonna have to pay
more in taxes these people are gonna
have [ __ ] rights oh my god they're
gonna want paid more they're gonna want
better [ __ ] health care they're gonna
want all this stuff
they're gonna want better roads better
communities they're gonna they're gonna
wanna make sure their children get
educated halfway decent these [ __ ]
people are going to want all this stuff
we're screwed
so they're going to put the fascists
back in power
that's what happens
because they don't want you to have
labor rights they don't want you to have
rights to your bodily autonomy they
don't want you to have rights to health
care they don't want you to have rights
to [ __ ] education they don't want you
to have rights in general
especially [ __ ] voting rights [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you can vote god damn you're a
threat you're a threat to fascism
you are a threat to corporate fascism
[ __ ]
especially
if you band together and organize which
we're doing
and we should continue to do we should
continue to lean into democracy [ __ ]
those [ __ ] [ __ ] them
lean into it
really get with it have that strategic
outrage
get [ __ ] pissed off and engage in
your ballot
engage in your democracy be a part of
the community
they won't stop they can't stop us if
that's what we do they cannot stop us
there's nothing they can do to stop us
no even calling for riots where are they
gonna riot
when you go out this november
and you take our country back by
engaging in your democracy
and getting your fellow community
members to engage in their democracy
even just bare minimum getting them to
vote
but really engaging making sure they
understand what's at stake because i
think more and more people are waking up
to what's at stake
well where are they gonna go to ryan
every county [ __ ] election office you
really think there's enough of these
[ __ ] toothless gravy seals to go to
county offices and overturn every single
election [ __ ] no
what are they gonna go to every single
secretary of state
[ __ ] no there is there is there is no
one place that they certify all these
votes
like they certify the presidential vote
every four years at the capitol which is
a thing we should do away with we do not
need our congress and our senators to
certify the vote that's already [ __ ]
certified you don't need to do it if
you're gonna have the electoral college
then fine good but you don't get to
certify the vote at the capitol
you can do some kind of [ __ ] ceremony
where you deliver it to the the chief
justice so they can swear in whoever is
on the certification of the ballots that
[ __ ]
whoever we appoint should be able to do
enough [ __ ] math
on those envelopes to figure out who the
[ __ ] won and who to swear in
we don't need the congress to tell us
that they get they shared no you don't
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
but what are they gonna do what are they
gonna do in november
when these midterms happen there's no
certification in washington of these
votes there's no certification the
states certify the boats
the counties the election offices
certify the votes they count them
you really think there's enough of these
[ __ ] boneheads to go overturn this
election no
what they're going to try to do folks
is they're gonna try to put the fascist
in our government
that is how they want to overturn it not
with violence they tried that that
didn't work
that did not [ __ ] work
and it won't work
but they are going to try to make it
work inside our government
you just go look at history
of the 20s 30s and 40s
in nazi germany
and the way that the the fascists came
to power
in germany was through the government
not through violence
their coup their coup plot [ __ ]
failed hitler went to prison
and then they let him out
was the big problem and they let him
participate in politics another big
problem
but their attempt to overthrow our
government their attempt to undermine
your democracy
you the people
is not through violence that is just to
scare you to get you to not engage in
your democracy
it's to get you to fear that if you
engage in democracy that they'll commit
violence [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
you have to engage to save it
you better vote while you still got the
right
otherwise they're going to take that
[ __ ] away from you
use it or lose it baby
so now's the time now is the time on a
day like today labor day
where it is our country's history for
the people
the people to band up and organize and
say [ __ ]
no you are not going to take advantage
of us
we do not
have to be have to be grateful for you
you have to be grateful for us
that's what you have to do we have labor
to trade and we're going to trade it at
the highest price [ __ ] and we're going
to organize to do that whether you like
it or not that is our right in this
democracy the same thing we should do in
november
we have to rise up and engage in our
democracy stay focused stay pissed have
their strategic outrage
towards these manga fascists
because that's what is on the ballot
these manga fascists want to take away
your way of life they want to take away
your rights they want to tell you who
you can marry who you can love who you
can [ __ ] what your what schools your
children can go to what church you can
go to rather you can go to church or not
they want to tell you what medical
procedures you can get
they want to tell you that they can
marry your young little children in
tennessee they don't care
they want to tell you when you can and
cannot live
whether you're a 35 year old in texas
who has a dead fetus and can't get a
medical procedure to save your life
and you go into septic shock and die
or a little a little girl in florida and
force her to carry a baby to term
because she's not mature enough to make
a decision about her body
but she's damn sure mature enough to
carry a baby to full term [ __ ] you
it's time it's time we had enough enough
of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
we don't have to listen to these maga
fascists when it comes to our country
we can reject them now and in the next
election and in the next election
and if a republican party emerges that
isn't a bunch of [ __ ] outright nazis
then maybe just maybe just maybe
just maybe
we will let them have a little bit just
a little bit of power in our democracy
but until they prove
we have to reject them no across the
board if there's an r next to your name
we have to assume you're a [ __ ] manga
republican we have to assume you're a
[ __ ] maga fascist we have to assume
that you're america first nazi and we
have to treat you as such
so don't forget to engage in your
democracy on a day like labor day it's a
day to reflect on we
the people it's us it's our government
just like the labor production in this
country is ours it's [ __ ] ours the
people who trade the labor not the not
the people who pay us for it it's not
their [ __ ] labor it's ours
just remember that as we go forward and
as we go forward support pro-democracy
speech everywhere if you'd like to
support this show we appreciate it here
support
support.tonymichaelspod.com the link is
down below it's also in the description
you can also use the qr code there if
you'd like to support the show we
appreciate all the support you can give
whether it's monetary support or just
support watching listening sharing this
with your friend family friends sharing
it on social media sharing our clips
around don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel you're not going to want
to miss a single thing
here on the tony michaels podcast you
can also support us by following us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod and you can
also download every single episode holy
moly you guys are downloading these
episodes like crazy we have so many new
listeners so many new viewers thank you
to the entire audience you are why we
are here every single weekday it's you
without you listening without you
engaging without you downloading without
you speaking out in the chat in the
comments
sharing it with your family and your
friends
we would not this would not be possible
so it is you and we thank you on a date
like today on a holiday for being here
with us because radio never sleeps baby
and neither do i
let's let's go to a break when we come
back we'll have the [ __ ] list shitless
roundup right after these messages don't
go anywhere we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us here on this
holiday
labor day
because that radio never sleeps
i'm not gonna give up every single
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central ninth pacific as long as i can
broadcast we're gonna broadcast i don't
care what day it is monday through
friday two full hours every single
weekday
every single weekday
on youtube twitter and twitch and also
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page
super super
super important that you subscribe here
on youtube you're not going to want to
miss a single episode
we got some we got some new merch
doubt me merch
everyone was wanting to doubt me merge
doubt me
doubt me he's going to get indicted
doubt me i dare you he's gonna get
indicted here
so if you want some doubt me merch go to
store.dtonymichaels.com
get your stickers your shirts your
hoodies coffee cups we love coffee here
at the tony michaels but i i like coffee
here at the tony michaels podcast
thank you for joining us today on this
monday this labor day holiday
it's all for all the new listeners out
there we go through the shitless roundup
we go through the tweety tweets and
trendy trends and boy do we have a lot
of video from the nazi rally in
pennsylvania this weekend
holy moly do we have a lot of video i
got one i definitely want to show you
it's from the good liars now the friends
of the show here they are they are
fantastic absolutely hilarious and not
only are they hilarious but they show
the hypocrisy and the dumb buggery
of these manga fascists it is incredible
it's great it's fantastic i i can't i
can't i've watched it several times i
can't stop laughing every time i watch
it so we're gonna watch the top secret
documents video from the good liars as
well is watch the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants absolutely go
bonkers on stage
and pretty much incriminate himself i
also want to get to the marco rubio um
video
about how it's just the storage issue
it's just the storage issue that's all
it is it's not like he stole
classified documents it's not like he
was he was making sure that anyone could
see them in his office having them in
his desk drawer it's not like it's not
like there's a bunch of empty folders
where the top secret documents are poof
gone he either [ __ ] destroyed them
which is illegal he either sold him
which is illegal
or or he put him in a casket somewhere
which is also illegal
come on man storage storage my [ __ ]
ass let's get to the shitless roundup
let's surf the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the [ __ ] list roundup where
we round up all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends this is one of my
favorite segments we do this every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific for
two full hours where we go through the
tweety tweets and training trains we
bring you the news not like cnn brings
you the [ __ ] news
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
that's right i'll say it i don't care
i'll say exactly what the words that are
on my mind [ __ ] cnn [ __ ] them if they're
gonna turn and do this stupid hunter
buying laptop [ __ ] and they're gonna act
like this guy isn't a [ __ ] fascist
and somehow we're gonna both sides the
issue that is not what we [ __ ] do
here we do not both side the issues
there are not two sides of an issue
there is the pro-democracy side that is
it
that is it if you don't like that then
you're a [ __ ] fascist [ __ ] you
we don't have to [ __ ] placate to
their nonsense to their fascist weirdo
nonsense and let me tell you there's
some fascist [ __ ] weirdos these manga
fascists are [ __ ] weirdos
holy moly
and they're getting weirder and weirder
and here's why
because his support is dwindling down
right like as people are actually going
he stole what
he did what with top secret documents
he's admitting that he had him oh my god
at first they were planted but now he's
admitting that they had him
he's even saying that he can just wave
his hands and declassify these things
isn't that dangerous to declassify
documents without really considering
what documents and what the
ramifications
to our national security just
declassifying [ __ ] piles of documents
even bill barr said it
i'm telling you he's losing support not
gaining it
there's no way in hell no way in hell do
you believe that amer the american
people
are going to be excited about this guy
who stole top secret documents destroyed
them sold them whatever the hell he did
with him
and then he declined he's saying he
declassified piles of documents without
even knowing what you know he didn't
know there's no way the [ __ ]
knew what was in the boxes
all of it now each piece of it he knew
it had to do with him and it benefited
him i mean cash patel i believe was
i mean that's what we're seeing the
evidence is showing that cash patel he
even said he was in the room when he was
waving his hands over the eye his big
mac stained hands over the documents
to [ __ ] declassify them or whatever
the hell they're saying which is not a
thing it's not a thing
it's not and even if it was a thing like
bill barr said that [ __ ] fascist is
like whoa that's a step too far there
nazi
even bill barr was like nope way too far
way over the line nope two two two 1930s
1940s germany for me
even billboard
and it's not a good look
but it's dwindling down to the weirder
and the weirder
and the more devoted manga fascist
sycophants these delusional sheep that
he has that come to these rallies
to make him feel good i mean they come
from all over the country i mean when he
went to pennsylvania it's not like all
the people that went to that [ __ ]
rally were from pennsylvania not even
close
these people follow him around like a
like a [ __ ] like a
some sort of [ __ ] cult
a head of a cult they're a cult they're
a [ __ ] cult
it's no more clear
and some of these [ __ ] videos from
this rally holy actual [ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ] so let's get into it
let's get to the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends here let's go to the uh
let's go to the the timeline here let's
just bring it up here um here is the uh
a couple stories from uh the judge news
from kyle cheney here who says judge
cannon has granted trump's request for a
special master to review the attorney
client and executive privilege
that trump was requesting
and she also says her order will not
stop the intelligence community review
of the records that is very important
unclear
how that's going to work so in other
words it's very weird because a special
master when they appoint a special
master
the actual review of the evidence that
they collect stops
right and that's what that's what trump
ultimately is trying to do here is
trying to stop them from looking at his
crimes the evidence of the crimes he
committed that's literally that's what
he's trying to do
he didn't understand that he could have
done this you know within hours of them
showing up at his residence starting to
collect this stuff he didn't understand
that because he's a dumb [ __ ] his
attorneys didn't understand that because
they're dumb [ __ ] they don't know they
have no clue he does not have anyone
representing him that knows anything
worth the [ __ ] they do not know their
head from their ass
now she's granting him a special master
but the confusing part again
is that the dni
is doing their review of the records now
what dni is doing is they're not dni
the department of national intelligence
is not doing
a review
of them in a criminal fashion what the
dni is doing the intelligence community
that is they're doing their
assessment of what damage he has done
and and again that's probably going to
go into the criminality when the doj
reviews the review of what damage he's
done
so that's gonna go into the criminality
of it but the dni is not doing a
criminal investigation into these
records they're trying to do an
assessment of our national security and
then the national defense information
that he put at risk
and who he got killed and what happened
do they now know methods that we have to
abandon do they now know people who we
have to now protect that cannot be out
there collecting information to keep us
safe and secure this guy is a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and that is what dni is gonna find out
what did this piece of [ __ ] do
with these records and what damage was
done the way that he handled them and
what he did with them
that is really important here that the
judge appointing a special master is not
going to stop that review
because more than anything
i believe that's why the department of
justice acted the way they did and went
and got those records because they
believed there was damage being done
to our national security
there was damage
because he had these records or who he
gave them to
or who he was [ __ ] showing them to
are gonna show them to i'm not saying he
took
secret documents out of [ __ ] folders
stuffed them in his pocket with the
[ __ ] hamburger rappers took him up to
his little saudi golf tournament and
traded him for the saudi golf tournament
where they paid him buku bucks to have
the tournament at betminster you know
where he [ __ ] buried his ex-wife in a
ditch maybe they ended some of them
ended up in a casket there i don't know
i guess only time could tell
or
to exhume the grave
but we know we know he's in bed with
saudis and we know that there was
payments made to his family members from
the saudis
so who knows maybe maybe maybe the uh
documents in those empty folders were
worth two billion dollars
maybe we should go to jared and find out
but here kyle cheney is reporting
um that judge cannon
is going to appoint a special master and
i actually believe that this is not
going to be good for trump
mike
any anytime he thinks oh yeah this is
going to be great it doesn't go well for
him because when you actually are under
criminal investigation not not
impeachment
take that out of your [ __ ] mind
people or the select committee those are
not criminal investigations
or tish james in new york that is not a
criminal investigation
those are civil those are congressional
okay
and and and now and political now these
are criminal investigations
that's the most important thing you have
to remember
is he is under criminal investigation
not congressional investigation
not political investigation not civil it
is [ __ ] criminal um kyle's also
reporting here here are the details of
canon's orders which bars doj from
reviewing the documents for criminal
purposes
which is very important special master
candidates are due september 9th
trump does not get his documents back
yet so it's not and that's probably what
he's thinking he's probably [ __ ]
posting it over on fraud social right
now why aren't they giving back my
documents they're not your documents
number one they're not yours the
documents aren't yours
they're ours
they're the united states governments
that's why they wanted them back in the
first place that's why nara wanted them
back in the first place
so there uh we're watching for two
things he says here
the doj appeal uh is this remotely
workable for od and i
and will the agency address it fbi is
part of the intel community so what kyle
is saying here is because the fbi is
part of the dni
and the dni is doing the investigation
and the damage that he does
done um and the judge is now barred the
doj for the time being which is the fbi
uh from reviewing the documents for
criminal purposes
so until we get a special master on the
ninth
which is later on this week which the
candidates will appear
and the doj can't look at this for
criminal purposes
so but the dni can look at this for in
intelligence purposes
to figure out the national security
damage that he has done
and i believe that is going to be the
sticking point here because that even
though that is going that's an
intelligence review that intelligence
review can turn into criminal evidence
against him so this special master thing
is not going to help him it's number one
it's only he's only gonna admit to more
crimes here
because he can't keep his [ __ ] mouth
shut he can't keep his [ __ ] pie hole
shut and we are actually i'm counting on
it
i actually like that dudes over on fraud
social
admitting to federal crimes yeah fine
[ __ ] him let him do it out in the open
hell to the yeah
every he doesn't understand that this is
not a political trial
this is not a political trial it's not a
congressional trial this [ __ ]
criminal [ __ ] this is not civil either
like in new york you were under criminal
investigation
is what you are
i don't think he understands this what
do you think gabe you think he
understands this i don't think he
understands this
that it's criminal investigations
yeah are we talking about special master
right now well we're talking about the
special master but we're also talking
about how he doesn't he keeps yapping
and talking and telling on himself
because he doesn't understand this is
not a civil investigation it's not a
criminal or a congressional it is a
criminal probe here and um
the news is here
just to get you up to speed if you
haven't heard yet of course canon has
appointed the special master but she's
only barring the department of justice
of doing
uh a review of criminal purposes
meaning that the dni
the intelligence community still has the
ability to review if he did any damage
to our national security which again i'm
saying that's not a criminal probe right
now but whatever they turn up whatever
damage he has done and whatever they
turn up for the damage again that can
turn into evidence for the criminal
investigation it just isn't a criminal
probe right yeah you know i also would
imagine that the dojs they i mean you're
looking at a judge who is from the
federal society who is appointed by
trump who is doing everything she can to
make it seem
like
she's doing she's she's helping trump
because i don't think it's going to
change the outcome the outcome is trump
is [ __ ]
and
well right so i mean so maybe she's just
using this as delay tactics possibly is
that yeah maybe i mean i look at it and
i say like there's not much that really
changes here and from what i've read
from other experts that you know again
have degrees and aren't part of the uh
the the trump mystery they're not maga
fascist you mean right right someone who
actually knows what's going on basically
what i've read is
yeah it like it was to be expected
considering her position and considering
her history with
with trump however it doesn't change the
fact that a special master won't
won't really do anything that
would indicate
other than like what would create a
different outcome
he's still [ __ ] he's still not
in a good position
but
it doesn't actually do anything to
benefit him in the long run
right so well i mean other than maybe
delay another week or so with the
criminals yeah because kneeler she wrote
allison writes here i'm breaking as
expected because i expected this too i
expected her to appoint the special
master there was no real reason for her
not to
because what's the disadvantage for her
or trump here at this point right and
really honestly it's gonna be a
disadvantage eventually but at first
glance it's like well why not because a
special master
they're awarded special um um abilities
and powers but that's it it's just
limited it's not they can't they can't
go beyond the bounds of the law right um
a trump judge um uh elene cannon ignores
the law and president and appoints a
special master and stops the
government's criminal investigation uh
review of the materials and i think
that's important but she also goes on to
say but allows the nat sec or or the
national security risk assessment to
continue which i think is the most
important part of this um she says
absolute bs which it is [ __ ] yeah
because there's no there's no there's no
judge in their right mind that would
look at what the doj's motion says like
look we already set this stuff aside
here's the inventory here's the [ __ ] we
set aside
you don't need a special master and if
he wanted one why the [ __ ] didn't he say
something three weeks ago like right
that's when you get a special master and
if the judge knew her head from her ass
which she clearly doesn't because she's
appointed by trump um it's not
surprising that he would appoint someone
who's a [ __ ] idiot to the federal
bench and the republicans would ram them
down our throats not surprising but
in this respect
she she is going outside of what is what
is normal which again
is not abnormal for someone who's
appointed by trump here but i don't
think this affects
the criminal probe this is not going to
stop the doj because the doj number one
is going to file an appeal here which is
going to take it out of this judge's
hands um and that's that's the thing i
think you know may really be the
sticking point here is that it delays it
long enough for the appeal to come
through and they're like no this is not
there's no reason for a special master
and the appeal
right exactly yeah so like when i look
at this i go yeah it doesn't really
change it even if they got a special
master whatever obviously like the
the prevention of a a criminal
investigation
okay
but even if um
even the criminal investigation can
continue outside of this evidence right
exactly so like even if you were to give
like even if national security was like
oh no this is criminal
then they could proceed that way right
this is stopping the doj from following
right now right but they're just looking
future from looking and reviewing yeah
and that doesn't mean it doesn't mean
that the doj couldn't come back later
once the national security
team has gone through to say like yeah
this is uh we make a case right now for
you to investigate and charge him with
this stuff
then the other part of it is
the doj i can imagine that doj was like
look we've got two outcomes that are
gonna happen either she says uh
your your uh your your recent appeal is
correct
and go forward with it or
we are going i'm going to deny in some
regard your appeal i'm sure they already
had that
that
kind of one or two outcome happening
ready to go
so i would imagine right now their
appeal
is more or less written
they're just going through to be like
all right she specifically said this now
we just have to like bring that here are
you saying are you saying the department
of justice is more prepared than trump's
legal team is that what you're saying
look i'm yes i am i'm just going to tell
you right now way more prepared
yeah yeah
i i would imagine well yeah they've got
one and then they've got two they're
contingency and they probably have a
third condition contingency plan and
it's one of those things where you're
like i wouldn't be surprised especially
because like as soon as they file a
motion on the trump side they're like
great cool clap back here's the actual
appeal right and they go through and
they're like even before i'm sure they
even started on it and they're like um
we're going to need more than
the 36 pages which by the way they they
did 36 or they had 38 after going away
well yeah yeah they asked for 40 and
they ended they ended up being a few
pages shy affordable because they're
like yeah we can do that we don't need
the whole 40 yeah yeah we can cut some
words here and there but i mean like
even then they were like look we know
we already know it's gonna be longer or
it could be longer
uh because we're addressing each single
bullet point of these ridiculous claims
um
so
yeah again you know from what i've read
and from what i've heard like the
special master thing we already knew
that wasn't gonna be a big thing because
it just goes in just supports the idea
that like there isn't any
there isn't any outcome that would
change with the special master
this stopping the doj from investigating
criminal obviously will be appealed and
then we'll have a federal judge that
does outside of her because it is crazy
i mean like you would assume
i mean that's the reason why trump did
it but you would assume
that if there was a judge
who was appointed
to a position
by the person that is being investigated
you would say um gotta recuse myself
because there's a conflict of interest
this guy got me my job
you would think that that is how a
normal person would do it right well
he's however and that professional would
say like i'm up and that's a good point
that's a good point because that's why
judge reinhold
um his decisions hold so squarely is
because he's a magistrate he's appointed
by the bench he's not appointed right
he's not a political appointment he's
appointed by the other judges at the
bench to make those decisions where this
judge is appointed by trump and he drew
this judge by luck right now i mean in
in in the fact that he went to a
different court to make to try to draw a
judge that he got yeah um but i mean
this is
this judge making this decision this
doesn't stop here they're all our
appeals and the doj like you said
they're a lot more prepared than and
habba bob and trustee um
trump's attorneys then
and and they've already got this appeal
probably damn near 90 written in the
first place yeah because they expect she
was gonna make two decisions she was
either gonna do it or not gonna do it
so they kind of have a game plan
probably already yeah i wouldn't be
surprised that by the afternoon that
their appeal is already filed um once
they actually do a review of their
appeal
and they actually take it through a
process that they're willing to say well
this looks like a professional appeal as
opposed to written in crown which is
most of the time there i do i do wonder
if so each at each point when the doj
has to respond it has to file
um
you know documentation to say this is
what we did or you want it unredacted or
unsealed or whatever each time those
things are are given to the public on
the like
in in the court
more and more damning information comes
out so part of me thinks
like the judge again has already seen
what i would imagine is probably
everything
which i feel like is already kind of
shady that the fact that again it's a
judge that was appointed by trump
part of the federal society
is looking over this case with trump
and has seen certain things that you
know
i don't know well
you know whatever if the judge commits
crimes here then the judge commits
crimes i mean right right but
it can be prosecuted so i look at this
and
i
i imagine
that uh
that the doj might release something in
addition
right to be like
you mean another nugget is that like the
photo and then
in the actual list
you know you'd figure the the right wing
maggie nuts would love something with 2a
in it but
they they released the exhibit 2a
and i would imagine at this time they
could they could release like oh this is
or uh this is 1a or this is 2b or
whatever it is right
um i could imagine that they release an
additional
piece
of information
a photo or something else from the
investigation be like look
you guys keep trying to drag this out
this was never intended to be a public
display
of the court but because you keep
challenging we need to keep showing why
this is a big problem
so part of me thinks that they could
very well just release another little
nugget of information whether it's a
photo or a screenshot or something else
um maybe they could release uh maybe
they could release
um marco rubio's dignity um i mean that
would be a thing that they could
probably well you have to find it first
well it's probably in a box down there
at mar-a-lago i'm just saying
um you know this [ __ ] guy did you see
this video of him talking about this
what an idiot who the hell is he trying
to fool here who are these manga
fascists trying to fool this is the same
guy i don't know if you watched some
videos this last weekend to marco rubio
and lindsey graham and some of these
others rand ball be like he's a con
artist he's the biggest danger to our
democracy
yeah
when they were when they were
acknowledging the risk right right i'm
having this before this is when they
were all running for president right
well they're all like we need to say
something that separates ourselves from
him and though you know they everything
they said was true
right as soon as he got the nomination
they got down on their knees and they
put their cheeto desk knee pads on huh
they got ready and they said oh yeah no
this this guy's great he's great he's
gonna be a great president yeah
he knows how to unite
never divisive
doesn't run on hate does not run on a
platform of hate and xenophobia he's
great
right
okay marco little marco
um there's another video marco out there
really trying his best not to talk about
taking away uh women's bodily autonomy
in florida because there is one there's
one crazy thing about florida as crazy
as you think it is they are not they are
not for taking women's bodily autonomy
away majority of people in florida even
if they vote fascist they don't like
having their bodily autonomy at risk
and marco rubio and
and ron desantis are really trying hard
not to talk about abortion so there's
that clip too but this clip here is
specifically about the boxes of top
secret documents that the cheeto dust
mobster stole from us and stole from our
government and has probably either
destroyed them or sold them to somebody
he thinks it's a storage issue
um let's listen and i'll rip his ass
apart this is really at its core a
storage argument that they're making
right they're arguing there are
documents there
they don't deny that he should have
access to those documents but they deny
that they were not properly stored i
don't think a fight over storage of
documents
is worthy of what they've done
okay now this is all [ __ ] nonsense
okay and i said in the first half an
hour this is all [ __ ] nonsense here's
why
here's why he is not
he is not allowed to have those
documents that is all [ __ ] yeah what
what the government is saying
is those he is holding those documents
in a place that they should not be
right this is not an issue of storage
this is an issue of criminality of
holding these documents
unsecurely yeah and possibly giving them
away destroying them and committing
espionage they would not have the
espionage act if it was if that was the
case right well this is also the same
person and the same group of people
right now that at first they said there
was nothing there this was a clear
overreach uh this was done
he didn't have it there was something
there talking about
now they say yeah he has documents that
he shouldn't have because he had he said
out loud on fraud social that he had him
right right he's like yeah but when i
had him i had him in they they put him
on cartons okay they took him away from
cartons guys
but
this is the same group this is the same
party that
originally said there was nothing there
and this was an exaggeration and these
people should resign being merrick
garland and christopher wray now they
say yeah okay yeah yeah okay
he had the documents okay he had the
documents
but
this is a storage issue this is the same
[ __ ] group who went after hillary
clinton for a storage issue right which
was stored
stored files on a private server emails
that yeah they're like but the emails
are on a private server and they came in
and it's like yeah well they let them in
they could have whatever they want they
took the [ __ ] it was fine right
you mean you mean she changed the
storage of them is that what you're
saying yes it was a storage issue she
changed the story and if we're gonna say
that this is a storage issue which is
i don't know how many thousands of
documents in total have gone missing
right through all the different boxes
that they collected um
and all of the missing empty folder like
missing documents and empty folders like
who knows what was in there and how many
documents are in those folders but
they talk about this suggested this is a
storage issue that's all it is you guys
are over exaggerating this is a complete
overreach of the doj and the rule of law
just just accept the fact that he
misplaced the documents and that's all
it is right you misplace all the stuff
you lose coins on the couch where's the
remote control i don't know it's
somewhere in the in the in the house
we'll find it right the storage issues
storage where are you storing
where did i put my my face mask oh it's
in the back pocket of my pants it's just
a storage issue that i just misplaced it
listen that if you go back to the remote
if you go back the remote of the change
in the couch this is like if your friend
comes your your shitty friend comes over
of your house you don't know why he's
your friend you really don't know why
you even invite this [ __ ] in
your house he's such a [ __ ] box he he he
sexually molests women he brags about it
he he he he's friends with pedo
pedophiles
he grips people he takes people you know
he takes their money from them and does
nothing and gives nothing you invite him
over your house you let him on your
couch and he takes your change and your
remote no you actually know what i let
me let me on let me correct this for you
you don't invite him over this is a
goddamn no no this is a play date right
your parents instead of like oh yeah a
little little jimmy can come over he can
come over and you're like i don't really
like little jimmy and they're like no no
he's fine it's fine he's just you know
it'll be fine he's like
he took a [ __ ] in my closet and you're
like what are you talking about and he's
like no no no and it's like fine [ __ ] it
whatever
he comes over and then he steals the
remote control he steals your goddamn
legos like when i was a kid i had a i
had a play date and this kid stole my
goddamn holographic charizard card
and then was like oh i didn't take it i
didn't take it and then i found out he
did take it
this is that exact same thing it is it
is a person who is uninvited right you
didn't want them there they came into
the white house they came into your
house i didn't want them i didn't
approve someone else did
and then they come over and they just
take what they think is theirs right it
is a is a possession of property
possession of property is not like in
this scenario not intense of the law
does not mean that it's yours okay and
then when they find out they got your
stolen property it's like oh it's just a
storage issue i'm just storing it for
him i would i didn't actually steal it i
was storing it i was storing it but that
would be the same thing it's like oh
well you know like for the kid who stole
my pokemon card it's like oh well
wait it was in a case i just have an
empty case right now where did the
charizard card go right like it is that
scenario of like i have the thing what
was that what's a charizard card what is
it charizard yeah i don't know what this
charizard pokemon it is the holographic
oh pokemons it starts with charmander oh
i know i know come on pokemon yeah i
don't know about pokemon dude pokemon
he's gonna be gonna be all up in our
private text later but boomer don't know
pokemon and you [ __ ] i know i don't
know but this is the same thing whatever
it could be a collectible baseball card
michael jordan card
michael jordan okay chicago bulls boom
there was a card which i did have wasn't
stolen but you put them in
you have michael jordan no no no
i've got a lot of i've got a lot of good
micro courts they used to be worth a lot
way back when oh yeah yeah yeah well
cards have kind of come back and they're
they've actually
uh
this would be the same thing if the kid
took a michael jordan card and i had it
in a little case that said like oh
here's the you know mint or here's what
it was it's a little case
and then i find the case
and he's like well i just took the case
no i did not get the card back i didn't
know simply asking no because when i
found out when i found out the kid who
took who stole my pokemon card he'd
already sold it
[ __ ] yeah but this is the same
thing same goddamn thing do you think
that guy you stole your card votes for
trump
100 percent
100
that's a [ __ ] trouble right there
lived at the end of my block on the
corner he had he had a sister that was
in my grade and so because she had a
play date over at our house he tagged
along because he didn't have anyone to
hang out with then i find out that he
stole my [ __ ] card and then i found
out like hey this is weird like i had it
in this one spot and i had shown them
you'd be like oh here's my collection
we were playing whatever
he at some point dipped out took the
card boom gone son of a [ __ ] that was
it son of a [ __ ]
well
i want to show you how much the speaking
of
maga fascist did you watch some of these
clips from this rally these [ __ ]
weirdos these fascist weirdos it is
weirder and weirder now this is the this
is the good liars
um they're they're incredible yeah
comedy team and the satire that they do
but this video here only gives you a
good idea
of exactly how boneheaded these people
are and how they have no clue
no clue
about what is happening down in
mar-a-lago now a lot of americans are
waking up and going ah this guy's a
[ __ ] criminal but still the the
dumbest of the dumbest the delusional of
the delusional that the ones he really
can grift
are still just blinded by
by their cultness but let's watch
as um he's passing out top secret
documents here this is hilarious hey
guys welcome to the trump rally get free
top secret documents just for coming in
free top secret documents just for
walking into the trump rally yeah he's
giving them out to everybody i'll take
him take him it's fine i'll declass
they're declassified declassified there
these are the classified documents
um let me see if i got one there
oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm declassifying those those are
declassified so we're good hey guys
welcome
this is literally the the cult members
this is literally what they think donald
trump can do right like and that that is
the craziest part about this whole thing
is this this is what they're claiming he
can do is if this was donald trump he
could just hand these out to anyone he
wants he can declassify it he could just
wave his hand over him declassify him
and they're not really fooling on fully
understanding because again that's not
how the process works the process of
declassification involves the party that
actually gave them the classification
status you can't just then go around and
be like well this is you know i don't
you know this is not what it's like okay
guys guys guys it involves the people
like the people who said this should
have a say and they do have a say
because there's a protocol that you
follow there's a process there's a
hierarchy of who needs to be involved
you can't just unilaterally just be like
declassified declassified declassified
you've got karl rove you've got uh uh
bill
you've got other people from the
republican party people from his
administration that are like yeah this
is not how it works at all
well you know there's someone in the
chat saying all you got is empty folders
the problem with that is do you
you're you're dumb ass you're [ __ ]
sick of fat delusional dumbass you
little cultist you [ __ ] little manga
fascist cultist the problem that you
have here is that folder wasn't [ __ ]
empty if you actually think donald trump
stole
top secret folders if that's really what
you think that he stole them number one
that is a crime too you can't just have
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
can't just steal
[ __ ] from the government that is the
point here that's the point just because
he would declassify something even if he
would declassify something he still
cannot steal it he still cannot bring it
down to mar-a-lago he cannot but other
people who don't have security
clearances to see the the actual
markings of these ndi documents no
matter the classification he can't let
them see them he has to protect him it's
his [ __ ] duty that's the whole point
of taking an oath that's the whole point
of being trained on top secret
information confidential information you
[ __ ] little troll so if you're in the
chat here and you're like oh empty
folders you are a dumb [ __ ] you
are a stupid bastard and you are going
to be highly disappointed highly
disappointed
and what is going to happen in the
criminal investigation into those empty
folders cause those [ __ ] were
not empty to begin with because i said
in the beginning if you think if you
think that donald trump stole anything
that doesn't benefit him personally you
are out of your [ __ ] mind you're out
to lunch you're lost there's nothing we
can do to get you back
not a goddamn thing we can say not a
goddamn thing we can do you are [ __ ]
lost but he stole these documents he
took these documents our documents
because they have to do with him and
they have to do with probably [ __ ] that
he did that is classified and who he
could get revenge on that [ __ ] gave
information about him
it's all about him all the pictures he
took were of him
all the documents that he stole were be
because they had to do with him
that's the problem here that you have
with your little imp oh he just had
empty folders no they were empty when
they found them that's the problem
because there's there are four there are
four possible scenarios and we were
chatting about these around the phone
one he had the documents in the folders
right at the white house
he got rid of them somewhere that's a
crime
he transported them to mar-a-lago they
got lost
lost in transit that's a crime he took
them down to mar-a-lago and then said
i'm going to sell them i'm going to move
them around to someone else
that's a crime
he then said or it was down in
mar-a-lago
and then while it was down there and
people random people like kyle rednous
and his family lauren bober marger
taylor green any of these other people
who go down to [ __ ] kiss his ass
had access not to mention other people
that we know have been able to sneak
into the grounds of mar-a-lago and fake
uh their own identity and then later on
we find out that these people were
either faking to be a rothschild faking
to be uh someone else who was a chinese
spy right
mar-a-lago was not secure so the fourth
possible answer is not only did he try
to sell them possibly but
he had them in mar-a-lago in his office
someone had access that should not have
had access and stole them again another
crime so any way you look at it he's not
just collecting an empty folder to take
an empty folder because what does that
do why would he have a ton of empty
folders right like he said well maybe he
would print out maybe he would maybe
print out dick pics and put him in there
as a pickup line or some [ __ ] who knows
oh god who knows but i don't even want
to i don't even want to imagine that
scenario right in either one of those
four possible ways he either lost before
he left he lost it in transit he sold it
at mar-a-lago or someone stole it from
him in mar-a-lago either way you someone
on here defending that he just had empty
folders is complete [ __ ] because at
any point along the way of those four
scenarios because you have to now tell
me where the [ __ ] did those documents go
if the folders were empty
and either one of those is a [ __ ]
crime that's right
well and and and here's the thing
here's one of the videos that went
around this is again like two and a half
million views just on this one video
where he's talking about zuckerberg at
his rally do you really want a person
who having classified information is
laying around everywhere who doesn't
even know what [ __ ] weak it is yeah
i'm that serious or doesn't not only
what weak it is but doesn't know
what his home is well
he is a [ __ ] idiot here he in this
clip he's talking about zuckerberg and
meeting with zuckerberg and having
zuckerberg kiss his ass but he thinks it
happened last week at the white house
right this is really weird listen to
this
and then again i'd hate to we're gonna
have to watch a lot of him talking today
but this is what we gotta do you can't
look away you gotta know what this
[ __ ] idiot is doing you remember in
the campaign i used to say if these
people get in we're gonna end up with
venezuela on steroids i said it many
many times what the [ __ ] does that even
mean venezuela we always try to use that
they go venezuela it's socialist the
economy this and that that is not um
okay people should look up the history
of venezuela right because we do not
have we don't have the time to go into
that today
but they always want lauren beaubert
margaret taylor green they all use this
idea as venezuela is this evil thing
that is what happens when a socialist
type of government gets involved and it
just crumbles
that's right
there's more to it than that yeah the
venezuela thing is because they spread
this around on the chans the 4chans and
they eat chans and they spread around a
bunch of [ __ ] lines about venezuela
which is not the truth which really
honestly there's a lot of bad [ __ ] about
venezuela but if you're you're going to
call us as socialist as venezuela you
obviously have no [ __ ] clue what
socialism is like you don't even you're
not even in the same universe as facts
but i love i love how this is news max's
um
broadcast i love how they're pimping
trump
throughout the whole thing they when i
so i i went through and i watched this
uh this broadcast and you're putting
together a what was that yeah what was
that that i think will be coming out
tomorrow and i'm breaking down these
just absurd things that he talks about
this is obviously one of them
but throughout the whole broadcast
they're selling gold coins they're
selling a book they're selling
huckabee's groomer book
yes there's another guy that has a book
they're selling a 401k
on here
which is just it's it's insane let me
see if i can find it
1k okay well let's listen to this while
you're looking for that because i want
to get to the zuckerberg part of this
because it's insane this clip is not
that long again it doesn't take very
long for his mind to melt on stage in
front of the microphone i never thought
it was much of a possibility
but i never knew people could cheat like
that not like that
i don't know last week
last weird last week last week remember
last week now i don't know
do you think it's possible that they
pulled a speech from like three years
ago and just stuck it in the
teleprompter do you think that's a
possibility here it is a possibility
when i when i saw this clip i'm like
that's probably what happened because
when you see him he's riffing and then
he goes back to the teleprompter and
that's when he says last week but let's
let's listen last week remember he said
last week what what happened
last week grandpa poopy pants weirdo
he's a weirdo
it really is funny that this guy this
guy standing in front of hundreds of
weirdos
hundreds of weirdos that are just as
weird if not weirder because i'm not
debating rather mark zuckerberg yeah
yeah yeah no i i i agree he is a weirdo
he's a [ __ ] he's a weirdo he looks
like very much like data from uh right
from star trek you put up you put a few
american flag shirts on him and put the
right kind of hat this guy definitely
fits in the crowd at this rally that's
all i'm saying mark zuckerberg would fit
in really well there just because he
looks creepy but let's let's listen mark
zuckerberg came to the white house
kissed my ass
what yeah he came where
he came he came to the white house okay
so let's break this down a bit so last
week last week the head of of facebook
the weirdo mark zuckerberg came to the
white house
is that even in its in in and of itself
mark zuckerberg going to the white house
in the last week is that true i don't
know that there's any evidence that mark
zuckerberg don't believe that
uh just just in that just in that
boundaries that is right i mean the only
thing that i remember seeing
is that
mark zuckerberg went on to joe rogan's
podcast okay so so that so so joe
rogan's podcast not the white house
right yeah i mean like
if i look okay
so so let's just let's tick through this
here yeah so
he came to kiss trump's ass now maybe
just maybe
trump's getting time confused and he
means last year two years ago something
like that i mean it would have to be
like 19 months ago at the very like that
is right 19 months ago is when he
literally left office right so it would
have had to i doubt that he between the
insurrection and trump getting kicked
out of the white house i doubt he was me
which means it had to be
twenty definitely one last last month so
we're almost talking two years now let's
say let's smoke this out here let's say
he misspoke and said mar he meant
he meant the safest place for documents
and storage on earth
that has no locks and they're laying
around his office and then his desk
drawer where kyle ridden house can get a
hold of him let's
and saudis and russian spies let's say
he meant mar-a-lago instead of the white
house okay is there any evidence that
met mark zuckerberg the weirdo went to
mar-a-lago and by the way why would
trump invite such a weirdo
to mar-a-lago within grabbing distance
of top-secret documents
i have no idea i'm trying to figure this
out because he hasn't been at mar-a-lago
trump has been at bedminster so now okay
so now we got to take the maybe he meant
betminster and because bedminster you
remember when he was president-elect his
little house of bedminster he kind of
makes it like it's like it's a fake it's
like a fake white house like if you were
gonna shoot a movie and you wanted to
shoot it it kind of looks like a fake
white house like a really small one
and a really
you know tacky one
but maybe that's what he's thinking okay
so as i read this
it's a strange story
to recall mr trump's memory of a 2019
dinner that mark zuckerberg and fellow
tech billionaire peter thiel which if
anyone knows peter thiel
you'll know the influence that peter
thiel has in politics
uh so this is so wait so you're saying
that the last meeting that they can find
of trump i recorded me with trump and
zuckerberg number one peter theo is
there oh jesus this is yeah that's gross
but number number two it's in 2019
2019. what do you think they were eating
what do you think they were eating big
macs uh probably what do you think
because because well there's another
because there's another part of this
video as we keep playing that's going to
be like
what like there's a moment there's a
there's a what was that this is the
moment i think i mean there's a few
moments from this speech where i'm like
what the [ __ ] but this might be
i believe this is going to be the what
was that moment this clip of zuckerberg
because it's not only just this of him
saying he went down to mar-a-lago but as
you play in a moment there's another
moment there's another bit of his speech
about zuckerberg and facebook that makes
no sense right well here's the thing and
here's what i think happened i actually
don't think this guy forgot where he was
at i actually think he is reading off
the teleprompter they wanted to put the
zuckerberg bit that he has done in the
past
in this speech they pulled it from prior
i bet if you go back and look and try to
find a [ __ ] speech with mark
zuckerberg talking it he says almost the
exact same [ __ ] and they pulled it just
like they [ __ ] did his motions for
the [ __ ] judge and they didn't
[ __ ] rewrite it to be current and
it's and it's an old comedy bit that
he's trying to do on stage because let's
face it that's what he's trying to do
here is is stand up he's not actually
doing policy he's not actually you know
giving any kind of intellectual you know
production here it's only for him and
himself and his [ __ ] to stroke his
ego but he i bet if you go back and look
i bet you can find this speech somewhere
in 2019 after
mark zuckerberg came and visited him
with the [ __ ] scumbag peter thiel but
let's listen to the rest of the speech
sir i've looked after the
see there it is sir i'd love to have
dinner yeah here it is i almost bet
that's it let's listen sure i'd love to
have dinner i'd love to bring my lovely
wife
all right mark come on in
sir you're number one on facebook i'd
like to congratulate you oh thank you
very much mark and that is where things
don't make sense because he's not on
facebook right because he was kicked off
of facebook he was banned
this is a script from 2019 he's got a
bit he's doing a bit from 2019 because
this is when he still had facebook
because remember after the insurrection
right he was banned
i think he's got a two-year ban on his
name
that would mean that he could not be
number one because his account is not
active no one could see the account he
is not number one on facebook
so
this is
another either moment of this guy
talking out of his ass about something
he thought legitimately was last week
and he thinks he's still on facebook or
somebody just copy and pasted some
section of a script he gave
or a speech he gave
years ago in either 2019 or 2020 and
uh they just they're like yeah [ __ ] it
we'll go with it and here's the thing
no one in that audience
stopped to be like what
yeah right in that audience was like
yeah
no sense makes no sense because if you
stop and think about it for a moment
you'd be like wait
he
he's not on facebook he's he's [ __ ] on
facebook he shits on on twitter and
talks about how it's all about truth
social because he also talks about true
social in this speech as well he's like
who's not too social everyone's loved
truth
well here's the thing here's the thing
is that i almost i almost bet 100
doubt me on this doubt me on this
speaking doubt me go get your doubt me
merch
um
go get your doubt me merch
t-shirt stickers coffee mugs because
doubt me on this doubt me on this game
i'm telling you this [ __ ] part of his
speech is from 2019. they lifted it from
it's a bit from another speech that they
lifted because they wanted to smack
facebook and he he here's the story he's
not mentally incapacitated but he is
getting less and less help from his
staff and from people who are handling
him because they are finding out that
this guy is done he's [ __ ] finished i
wonder i'm trying to remember too as i
go back because the speech the speech
was two hours he stood up there for two
[ __ ] hours and talked
right uh you think he could do two hours
today i doubt he could do two hours no i
don't think so i think he did the two
hours and he was like okay time for nap
nah time for nap okay uh but he'd need a
lot of adderall to do two hours a day
yeah well i'm flying right beforehand
you know his costco size bottle veteran
but
when i look at
this uh there was a moment in the speech
where he does talk about facebook and he
talks about how facebook he's like oh i
heard the news about facebook
suppressing a story about you know
hunter biden and the laptop from hell
and blah blah blah
so there's a part of me i'm trying to
remember too if those those two points
were connected
right like when he said one he brought
up the other
and he just like went into some deep
deep crevices i don't know maybe he's
reading off the script or this might be
one of the moments where he just like
[ __ ] riffs on something right he just
takes an old bit that he pulls out of
his head yeah
who knows well i mean here's another
little weird i think this is the weird
moment here where he's talking about um
president xi and putin oh yeah yeah this
is really [ __ ] weird and listen
because they cheer him on so much stuff
that you're like why are they cheering
for that but in this moment if i'm
getting this one correct in this moment
like it is crickets and it's kind of
[ __ ] funny watch pierce you're smart
you know a lot of times i'll say
somebody's smart and the fake news will
go he called president she's smart
yeah why would he
can you stop that right there yeah
yeah
of course because you just said he was
smart so if you say he's smart in the
mainstream media the fake news says
donald trump said he's smart
where is the lie right where is the lie
here you said putin was smart and then
the media said trump said putin was
smart
right i'm not seeing i'm not seeing how
it's not true
like how is this a lie it is not such a
[ __ ] buffoon but listen to where
he actually leans in
to wanting to be a murderous dictator
he wants he leans in
again
he loves communist china he [ __ ]
loves it and the reason why he loves it
and you'll hear why here
he rules with an iron fist 1.5 billion
people yeah i'd say he's smart wouldn't
you
what the [ __ ]
so he is smart because and does he know
what rules with an iron fist means
with an iron fist you know like that
makes him smart you know
he's a he's a
tyrannical dictator that is that is
smart this is not the only like
throughout this speech he also talks
about how he a drug dealer should get
the death penalty oh i'm going i'm going
to go to that one i'm going to go there
watch the crowd's reaction here though
when he when he says this watch watch
how they are like what watch you say
he's smart
so
nothing
nothing just he's like i gotta rebound
from that when you say he's smart
they're like
not not one person in the ground like
yeah not one also because
as
it's one of those things where he talks
about he's like china right
now he's like jen he talks about how
he's like
jan is bad like he talks about that but
then he's complimenting the person who's
ruling over china with an iron fist
right
it makes sense
china bad but but president xi good
right right and that's that is what they
want for this country they he wants to
be a dictator he wants to put people in
concentration camps like she is doing
with muslims he wants they he wants to
be able to control every facet and every
part of the economy they want to have
full control over people and what they
can and cannot do they want
absolute fascist control
and they want to destroy our country
just like china
does
just like xi does to china now this is
his plan here um we've been doing this
war on drug thing for many many decades
since since richard nixon really and a
lot of people have come to understand
that the war on jugs drugs is um [ __ ]
stupid um and it wastes a lot of our
[ __ ] money and really honestly it is
it has delivered us a bunch of fascists
inside of our law enforcement um
and and also
fill up our prisons full of
men
in particular of color
and people of color
but here is his plan
gabe for drugs this is it in in is 40
seconds long listen to his plan i'm sure
don jr was freaking out when he said
this by the way but let's listen
they kill 500 people during a lifetime
and i think it's much worse than that i
think that's only what we hear about
it would stop it i if you didn't get it
down 75 80 90 from day one i'd be
surprised
and these committees that they set up
it's laughable it's a horrible thing we
would solve that problem so fast and i'm
calling on republicans and democrats so
he wants him to work together gabe here
he wants bipartisanship he loves unity
he loves unity in this respect let's
listen immediately to institute to get
to washington and institute the death
penalty for drug dealers you will no
longer have a problem
that is not how that works they all
cheer but you know what's funny you know
what um
you know what there is a death penalty
for a crime that a person commit if they
um if they steal top secret documents
and they and they break the espionage
act and they actually sell or give away
our national secrets to
foreign actors do you know what the the
um the penalty from that can be we've
actually we've actually done that
penalty to people in this country just
in the last hundred years do you know
what that penalty is
uh prison uh death oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah i mean there was a one it is funny
how he's projecting here well yeah
there's also one point i'm pretty sure
for treason you were tar feathered and
dragged through the the town square
right i'm not against that i know that's
really cool i don't know we don't have a
lot of we don't have a lot of trees and
charges in this country but i'm just
saying if we were to have you charges in
the near future i'm not saying we should
rule that out i actually think you could
sell tickets to that [ __ ] oh i'm sure
i'm sure you could maybe get 81 million
people to pay you know
reinvesting in the economy here right
but it is one of those things where
you know
the guy from the very beginning from the
very beginning of the speech
he was projecting he was talking about
uh how divisive
biden's speech was the most it was so
divisive it was full of hate
the the first time a sitting president
and it's like dude i could i could name
a handful of moments
while you were president that you gave a
hateful and divisive speech his first
one his first one american carnage
american carnage
but that's not even including oh yeah
yeah the 2015 to 2016
speeches and rallies where yes he comes
down the escalator right out of the gate
xenophobia right out of the gate [ __ ]
brown people yeah just hate them
calls them drug dealers rapist murders
like i didn't really appreciate that
but you know that's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that he is but then you go from there
and he's telling oh yeah beat that
person up i think cops should be more
aggressive
towards uh towards people who are like
um
uh are you know arrested or being dealt
with right you should rough them up you
know go go beat that [ __ ] or go that
son of a [ __ ] up over there i'll pay
for your legal fees at a rally you know
you're gonna tell me that this guy
like
isn't
isn't secretly talking about himself
like he has those wants and desires
right blame someone else right so when
out of the gate of this whole speeches
rally he says that that that the hate
and
uh and divisive nature of the speech by
biden was unnecessary it's uncalled for
but within within a matter of i want to
say a couple minutes he goes right into
attacking other people
and then the rest of the speech was an
attack on fetterman uh i'm going to show
that yeah it was a it was an attack
toward drug dealers toward any well i
mean i mean the drug dealer comment to
me really honestly the drug deal which
should freak down junior out he's like
whoa you're gonna do what to my drug
dealer my drug dealers jesus christ what
i actually think what trump is saying is
it's an attack on poc people of color
yeah yeah i i think that's what he's
saying is like like block black people
up that's what he's saying he's saying
um and not lock him up but execute them
and because he's i mean honestly the the
people who get caught the most as drug
dealers who who who are actually
thrown into the justice system because
of dealing drugs
are are black people and people
well they're not the higher ups right
you know right they're not going to be
people who are because you know the
people who are running are
they might be white you know but they've
got it they've got a structure where
they've got right the people on the
street and they get busted and maybe
those people flip to someone else but at
a certain point the flipping stops and
you can't get up to the height like the
person at the top of this pyramid that
is this uh this drug cartel or this drug
gang or whatever it might be well
someone says not his on youtube he says
not his adderall dealer
don't don't get it twisted they love
they love legal drug dealers yeah they
love legal drug dealers that's why they
love the sacklers you think the sacklers
are a bunch of democrats [ __ ] no no [ __ ]
no the shacklers aren't a bunch of
democrats hell no republican sangha
fascist to the core i mean part of me
thinks that ronnie jackson is the one
who's writing the scripts for him it
could be you know he's like maybe that
may be the special data that he was
harboring on january 6. it was like a
stack of adderall right he goes or just
a stack of scripts or he's like i'm out
of here now like i gotta i gotta save
this for later
i gotta make sure i gotta make sure old
skinny's got his got his adderall
because apparently ronnie jackson knows
trump's body better than anyone yeah
melania which he also talked about at
this speech god is so [ __ ] weird well
it's always the same [ __ ] it's always
the same [ __ ] let's listen to this
little clip here in philadelphia if you
look at atlanta
i have a district attorney in atlanta
she's after me for a perfect phone call
yeah you're under criminal investigation
there too what the [ __ ]
perfect phone call perfect phone call
right perfect it was a perfect vocal it
was one of the best okay you know it's
like do it do it again do it again
it was a perfect phone call it wasn't
perfect it was perfect
it's just it
you know people joked about
when the gen 6 committee had released
some
audio or i forget what what it was but
like
there's so much [ __ ] there's so much
[ __ ] but then people were making jokes
about he's like oh you know like i made
this and it was perfect
and then you find out that he's either
he's either the audio of him actually
saying these things or
him actually on stage saying this to a
crowd of people he's like oh it was a
perfect phone call there was nothing
wrong with it yeah sure i told him to
found about 11 870 votes so that i could
win the election right i committed a
crime on that look and it was like
different guys guys it's not a big deal
okay i asked for you know
some votes that i didn't have and it
wasn't just a few votes it was like
which already is a bad thing it was
thousands of votes it was over ten
thousand eleven thousand it was the
exact amount that he needed to win like
plus you know the exact amount plus one
right what he needed to be joe biden
let's let's listen to how he describes
this
perfect criminal phone call and yet it's
even worse proportionately than chicago
for killing but the district attorney
what
what does chicago the
murders in chicago have anything
they love to bring up chicago well this
is more this is more the black people
stuff yeah that's what this is this is
more of oh look look i'm committing
white people crime here okay and it's
perfectly fine for me because i'm who i
am to commit white people crime but i'm
going to distract you
with with crime that happens in a
predominantly black area
that's what i'm gonna do what if what
the [ __ ] does that have to do with this
what in the [ __ ] does chicago have to do
with you committing election crimes down
in georgia trying to overturn our
democracy what the [ __ ]
trump made a phone call yeah because he
was challenging
the election he was trying to overturn
it so they're after yeah
you weren't challenging it you you you
went well beyond challenging it and that
is actually what she's investigating is
to prove that you went way over the
bounds of challenging because that's
that's the uh that's the defense that
lindsey graham is using here he's like
oh i was just i was operating with my
senate powers from a totally different
state
like right it would be one thing if
lindsey graham was the senator in
georgia that would be one thing but he
is not
also also object
when it comes to challenging if i'm a
sitting president i go ah man you know i
feel like there's something a little
wonky about this doesn't make sense you
are not supposed to be making the one
with the phone call you do
literally do not call the this
you do not call the attorney general be
like hey go look i got a big problem
here or you call the secretary secretary
of state you know brad and you say hey
look i needed to find uh
11 870 votes you as a sitting president
in no way should be calling
to be like look
i need to win in order to win i got to
find these votes look i don't know how
you do it but i need you to get me these
exact votes
you know i mean like if anyone was
an athlete
and where to go hey look referee or some
other participant who's watching or
regulating the game i need you to add a
couple goals
to the score
so we win and like but everyone's
watching and we saw you play
you should not be are you trying to are
you trying to bribe me right now are you
trying to win this game illegally
because that's what it is
he's going there and he's trying to
manipulate the end result
himself for his own race right and he's
like guys is it totally it was totally
perfect it was great
he got caught being recorded by the
person who knew he was going to call and
asked him to commit crimes for him
brad rathersberger knew that trump was
going to call and ask him to commit
federal and state crimes on behalf of
him and brad ranchersberger had to wear
with all at least to record that
[ __ ] let's continue to listen to
tiny hands here wave them around perfect
by the way perfect
perfect just like the call
to you look at these people they're
convinced look at him he's like they're
like oh i've heard the tape and it
doesn't sound perfect i mean i'll still
support you because i definitely want
you to be the king because i'm a cult
member yeah but it was not perfect by
any means i mean look at just look at
here we got a okay we got a guy with
donald trump giving two middle fingers
we've got a guy who's got a camo hat and
glasses but a pin of trump on his hat
right we've got a woman that probably
says trump but it's bejeweled right
uh we got him definitely has her sweater
here differently says right and then we
got a guy over here with the trump hat
2024 probably we got a guy down here in
a red hat because oh man red is the
color of the devil uh that's what's
happening
right that's what they're all saying
is you guys literally have a payment
platform that's called win red right
under that logic and that would be
saying red wave yeah i mean like what
the [ __ ] don't understand even on tick
tock they had that song uh was like
dude i like that i forget how it's the
so [ __ ] chief song yeah yeah it's the
chief song but because chief's colors
are red right so they they kept using
that up you know through the election
after election about how this song was
the [ __ ] anthem for the republican
party it was so [ __ ] dumb but these
here you got a red hat down here that's
trump 2024 you got another you got
another two oh no you got another camo
hat
like
i've never seen and it's only at trump
rallies like the concentration of pro
the candidate gear
is insane
it's always with trump and people like
oh we're not a cult you guys are you
guys are sheep and it's like dude you're
all wearing the same thing all right
y'all have some permutation of trump
gear his face his name whatever
well i mean we see it in like walters
videos where
like they
they are such sheep about like their
gear that all she has to do is throw on
a trump hat and they believe that he
that's all you gotta do is wear a trump
hat they are so much ingrained into the
cult that as long as you put on a trump
hat it means that you believe the vile
[ __ ] let's continue here it was a
perfect call the one in atlanta was a
perfect fall that one that one not the
other ones just that one i guess i don't
know you know back to the red thing if
you look here even newsmax is a little
um thing is everything is right all the
signs
his [ __ ] tie is red oh don't worry
that's i literally have that in the what
was that i go the guy is i go the guy's
wearing a red tie
in front of a crowd of people wearing
red hats waving red signs
they even have a platform called win red
so under that logic
that would mean that it's
satan's money i guess i i mean that's
not where i go with it because i'm not a
[ __ ] but also can you can you get a
color make something satanic yeah i know
uh can you zoom in a little bit there
are these two guys that have been
they're like the
uh let's see i i have to do this and
then uh
you're talking about this one right now
that guy amish yeah yeah yeah and that
much there is pennsylvania yeah yeah no
i know but
if you watch them they because they they
also shift their wherever the is they
kind of shift over but
uh you mean newsmax or just because each
camera's kind of camera's a little bit
different right so on some of them
they're on his right shoulder on some of
them they're on his left shoulder
but uh yeah those guys man they are
i was like i would never have imagined
that amish people would be pro-trump but
oh they oh absolutely absolutely
i mean there's no there's no more
community that prohibits people from
having rights than a religious community
like
like the amish or mennonites i mean they
they use their religion
to keep their community tight i mean
that's the thing in this country is you
have a right to religion i mean that
that's what happened to some of the lds
um i forget what the the compound down
in texas was but they used their
religion as a cult i mean that's the
reason why so it's not surprising that
that almost the almost cult would be
part of this cult i mean but they
throughout the whole thing i kept once i
found him it was one of those things
like once you spot it you can't unsee it
all right so the whole time i was
watching the clips and watching the the
actual kind of speech i just was fixated
on them in the back like watching their
faces they're like looking up at what i
imagine was a jumbotron
uh but they were fixated and they were
so happy to be there and i'm like man
this feels so weird
um
regina and a few other people are
pointing out that they may be mennonites
and they may be mennonites um you know i
i've had a lot of experience with um the
mennonite community where i'm from
there's a
very close by there's a big mennonite
community um and we used to we used to
run into them in construction and stuff
because they have construction crews and
things of that nature right so uh yes
they could be either mennonites or the
amish um but a lot of people don't know
that there's different sects of of these
uh um you know pennsylvania dutch
whether it's almost midnight that sort
of thing but let's let's finish here um
and watch watch as if the amish switch
shoulders i don't know if they do what
gabe says but let's see
perfect call and yet atlanta is even
worse than chicago
so that's where he's getting this yeah
that's where it ties into chicago
is he's he's saying oh this prosecutor
is prosecuting me for committing crime
in atlanta but atlanta has worse crime
than chicago yep what i don't understand
what that even [ __ ] means really he's
he's trying to make the argument that
these areas that are questioning me
legally
shouldn't because they don't have their
own [ __ ] together
it's a mess over there it's a complete
mess there's so much crime and drug use
and this and that and whatever
why are they focusing on me what did i
do i did nothing wrong guys i made a
perfectly good phone call but they're
ignoring the people who are the actual
criminals the people who are because
also in the beginning of the speech he's
talking about oh you everyone you got
nice cars you like your cars well not
for long
like right out of the gate in in the
first few minutes of the speech outside
of like talking about
the red lighting of biden's speech and
how it was so divisive and hateful he
also talks about how the crime has risen
and those people who
have nice cars and like nice cars
don't don't expect to have them for long
because they're going to be stolen or
broken into like it's the fear-mongering
it's the they're coming for your suburbs
and they're gonna they're gonna come
after those white suburban moms and and
this and that like there's so much crime
and it's a spree and this is democrat
america and they don't have it under
control and the people who are
investigating me they can't even do
their own
uh state or city right because
it's a mess over there
did you send me a message here that
biden is possibly speaking
i don't see where he is speaking is he
he's speaking it's in it's in milwaukee
i'll give you the i'll give you the
thing yeah if you gotta if you got a cl
if you got a link there while we're
doing that i want to bring up dr oz was
on stage this is hilarious
and i know people in this audience have
been hurt by fentanyl i believe we could
have an economy that helps the american
people but most importantly
i believe in each and every one of you
and show you so if you hate fentanyl and
you want to
give drug dealers make sure to buy this
book
well yeah well all the other thing you
do is you give the sackler's uh death
penalty listen to how he says this here
though
listen
did you call him dr oz
so we have a great record of endorsement
all of us together it's very close to 99
no that is not true that guy and i'm
telling you wait wait what did he call
99 and i endorsed that guy and i'm he
doesn't even know his name yeah
[Laughter]
oh he doesn't want to say his name you
have this link for the um okay here's
the one yeah and then i also i also want
to show this so earlier i talked about a
401k what i had
the real thing it was pitching a
different gold coin and this is what it
was
trump rally limited offer get up to ten
thousand dollars
in precious metals for free
for free
with purchase
text trump to 989898
protect your ira or 401k from bite
inflation
get a free kit on gold now
this
is
they are using him they're using trump's
name
and i'm sure he gets a little cut of it
they're using his name
to
scam people out of money
this whole free information
you're talking about you're talking
about newsmax in general yeah well he
gets a cut of this no wait
text my name trump to these places to
get your gold kid to get the book to get
this to get that
it's all one big grip so he's in
milwaukee this is the birth of this is
the birthplace of unions let's listen
your child shouldn't have to worry about
turning on the phone by the way this
isn't this is an actual president saying
actual things to actual people let's
listen
look it's the biggest investment in
america since president eisenhower's
interstate highway act
and we made sure the infrastructure law
included significant labor protections
for example the majority of the funds
and law are subject to davis bacon
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's not just because i wanted to
help unions
it's simple
you're the best in the world that's not
hyperbole no you're real that's not a
joke you really genuinely are
but you just don't decide you want to be
a pipe fitter or electrician
it takes you four to five years of hard
work apprenticeships it's like going to
college you're the best trained workers
in the world and deserve to be treated
that way
[Applause]
and by the way
those who know me no one ever doubts i
mean what i say the problem is i
sometimes say all that i mean
dark brown i made the same comments to
the business roundtable to the chamber
of commerce they understand it they
don't want to pay it they understand it
though because it's true
i also signed the chip and science actor
groundbreaking law
we'll once again manufacture
semiconductor chips that power every day
everything our smartphone dishwashers
automobiles
national security center right here in
america guess what
we invented it here
we invented it here
in america
how unpatriotic of him by the way the
reason why last time out last year
inflation was so high
you know the biggest reason cost of
automobiles you know why they cost so
much they didn't have the computer chips
to make the automobiles
folks here in wisconsin senator baldwin
made clear that you're ready to take
advantage of this law
with
with world-class universities and a
workforce that knows how to manufacture
projects here in wisconsin this law is
going to create tens of thousands of
jobs america bringing billions of
dollars of investment here in america
well over a hundred billion dollars
investments in america revitalizing
american manufacturing you mean biden
actually did what trump lied that he
would do
where is it written
where is it written that says america
can't lead the world in manufacturing
where does it say that i want to be
clear if you're watching
joe biden's not standing in front of the
teleprompter he's holding the mic ohio
for the groundbreaking of a
multi-billion dollar semiconductor
manufacturing plant
the company is intel
it's one of the largest investments of
the kind ever they're putting 20 billion
in as a start
it's going to create thousands of jobs
thousands
7 000 construction jobs just building
the facilities
5 000 permanent jobs for blue-collar
workers who will make
125 000 a year in those jobs
and by the way if you take a look
manufacturers all over the world are
coming to the united states he's not
reading from a property here by the way
from all over the world why
you know why the head of the outfit out
of korea told me they're coming here
because we have the safest environment
and the best workers in the world
that's a fact
we do
i'm not just saying this this is real
again he's not getting fed this he is
just saying this just walking around
talking look folks
it means we're going to build
the future in america
with american workers and american
factories using american-made products
we need to get some up-close footage of
this speech and do more dark branding
something most people don't know but you
guys 125 000 dollar line i think that's
a good one 15 of our military
become veterans become union workers
when they leave the military 15
how many veterans out there
holler out
you got it
actually caring about helping veterans
come back for us
serving put forward what i call a unity
agenda including taking care of our
veterans
look we have a lot of responsibilities
and only one sacred responsibility not a
joke and i've been this from the bottom
of my heart and i've said it from the
first day i entered politics
we have an obligation to equip those we
send into harm's way
and care for them and their families
when they come home
both their families
especially our veterans have been
exposed
to toxic burn pits like my son those
pits
the size of football fields
eight nine ten feet deep in afghanistan
and iraq i was in and out of those
countries over 35 times
in the middle of these wars as vice
president
that incinerate waste of war tires
poisons chemicals jet fuel
so much more
a lot of people like my son had their
hoots just probably 300 500 yards from
those pits
you could smell it you could inhale it
well guess what
these poisonous fumes just came
people came home with headaches
numbness dizziness cancer
i just signed would call the pact act to
take care of these veterans
who need medical assistance
[Applause]
and to provide for their families when
they are gone do you know who voted
against it gabe you know voted against
it
republicans yep the maga fascist well
they don't care any anti-republican
that's what that's or anti-american is a
republican
it's at least
well i'd love you too kiddo i'll tell
you
[Applause]
look
like i said i believe we have a lot of
obligations
we have a lot of obligation only one
sacred obligation
that's to take care of those vets we
send overseas and when they come home no
i know i but i really mean it
and as i said i just signed in the law
historic inflation reduction act
it wasn't
to take on big drug companies but we did
i've been fighting them since i got in
congress 180 years ago
you know we paid more for prescription
drugs in the united states america than
any major country in the world i want to
point out something here as he's talking
about this um
that he was talking about veterans and
how he cares about veterans and he is
genuine about it and the reason why gabe
i think the evidence is there is because
he's the only modern president the only
modern president that in the last
several since george h.w bush has
actually which has actually had a child
who has served in the military
that i just want to point that out like
your senior senator
who you said
no i
i want to say what he said
he said he opposed lowering drug costs
because it would result in punishing the
pharmaceutical
industry bless me father for i have
sinned i mean
come on man
not this year we beat farmer this year
oh get that dark friend get it get it we
gotta get a close-up on that one we're
gonna change people's lives we beat big
pharma this year finally oh you gotta
find it
um i don't know what now medicare will
have the power to negotiate lower
prescription drug prices we can
guarantee we gotta protest the audience
no matter whether the bill is fifty
thousand no more than two thousand
dollars
period
you just witnessed
brandon live and you have diabetes your
cost eventually capped at 35
damn
you know i think i think the uh
by the way doing sign language should
have the darkness the reason that you
know how much it costs them to make it
easier when it heightens diabetes
so they know that it's dark rain and
speed yeah any of you have to you need
that insulin or your children you know
what it costs they cost you somewhere
between 650 and a thousand bucks a month
it's outrageous
well guess what
we also had in this bill of mine
we also had a provision that affected
people who weren't on medicare
but because of the leadership of your
senior senator and others it got
defeated
but i'm coming back and getting it
dark i'm not done right i'm not done
dark brandon rice's i like the dark
brandon thing uh as we wind down here
the show
can you put the uh
link to this in the chat for people so
they can go watch this video yeah as we
close up here because we're gonna close
up for labor day here if you want to go
continue to watch the president united
states who didn't take off today just
like we did not take off today it is so
important that we spread the message
just like he's doing there in milwaukee
joe biden the most pro-union present in
history the most pro-labor present in
history simply wrong is in is in
milwaukee
uh yelling and screaming and turning
into dark brandon i believe that is the
funniest part about the dark brandon
thing is these let's go brandon nazis
they really thought they were going to
take that and run with it and we've
totally stole it away from them and
they're like oh you think you're
worshiping
biting now like no we're making fun of
you really yeah like we're making fun of
you to show that
he's not sleepy joe he's not cool he's
not inept he actually is really doing
his job he gets up in the morning puts
his shoes on
and he just does his job and that's dark
brandon and you guys have no clue that
we're actually we're actually mocking
you
when we call him dark brandon or make
the dark brandon joke so hopefully we
can um get that that clip on a close-up
game and do a dark brandon for everyone
and put that out sometime soon so
everyone thanks for joining us on labor
day again if you want you can go watch
look
on the white houses did you put the link
there in the chat yep i did okay good so
everyone the link is in the chat there
if you want to go watch this white house
feed and finish watching joe biden you
can go it's on youtube it's on youtube
so you don't have to leave youtube you
can go over to that video um and and
watch the remainder of this speech but
everyone thanks for joining us today
again we broadcast every single weekday
monday through friday live on youtube
twitter and twitch new nissan 11 central
nine pacific and also simulcast from the
midas touch facebook page happy labor
day everyone still stay safe until
tomorrow same time same place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking